okay here you do Chloe we're here my
name is
polishing history and we're here today
in my capacity as director of the center
priority society and most importantly to
introduce James Brooks will presently be
presenting us as a talk entitled
connecting with indigenous communities
through indigenous art collections I
wasn't invited saying with the Center
for dr from society is its mission is to
serve as a kind of crossroads or
interface between the arts and
humanities in Carnegie Mellon as an
organization that exists the active
involvement of faculty members in the
schools are trauma music the
department's of English history apology
and modern
others Hunter just by definition an
interdisciplinary or better said
transdisciplinary enterprise and that's
one reason why today's event and speaker
are exciting for us I should begin well
I should reduce James but I should do so
by explaining all the ways in which i
come to know him and some aspects but
his work which is hard because he's done
and continue to do so many different
kinds of things one graduate student in
my seminar remember James hooded face it
just say etc a lot yeah I say that over
and over again you really have to the
first way I came to James and we like to
get business through the scholarship
James his book which I have in my bag I
should friendship new songs tonight
captors and cousins slavery kinship and
community and stuff with borderlands
which you know University North Carolina
for us in two thousand to correct a
radically innovative book I think we
safely say it's topic the emergence and
transformation of a captive exchange of
condomina southwest border lines from
the 16th of the late 19th century in it
Brooks introduces us to not one that
many Borderlands with different social
and physical geographies all of which
refuse easy identities conclusions and
rubrics here if you take some of the
keywords and his title slavery
discussion of slavery is quite
his focus on borderlands first of all by
the eastern and southern United States
and he focuses on a constellation of
indigenous spy American mixed-race
groups rather than African or African
ascended most importantly he looks a
kind of economy of capture and slavery
that was not based upon chattel slavery
say on a plantation model but rather
based on radically different kinds of
practices and radically different
history which is that strikes me as
enormously important to remember recover
so the vision of this kind of slavery
and capture that James resentence with
this reading is integrally related with
practices of capturing exchange and
frameworks of honor and shame of long
precedent in both indigenous and Spanish
sculptures loan for the conquest he
integrally relates practices of capture
and enslavement both between indigenous
groups I between groups of European
indigenous for mixed descent patterns of
economic exchange commercial activity
pastor own otherwise and a key feature
of studying against of an exception part
I think is is his study of kingship in
this context its captives and cousins
titleist work in other words those who
are taken as captives or slaves were
typically thought of as potential kin
and often over time
image of capturing group there are
profound implications of this work for
the analysis is one of the community
that emerged the borderlands James will
suggest have complicated questions of
community formation and definition but
common such scenarios whether for
Spanish finals Apaches Comanches or any
number of other indigenous or mixed race
groupings for instance the Usos and
finally he gives us a very discussion of
violence's is critically important it
gives us a very affecting picture of
systemic low-level violence or what he
called in our seminar today low
intensity piece which do not reflect a
breakdown of social order for
institutional control but precisely a
pattern of production and a social
reproduction that lay at the heart of
the making of Portland society etc etc
etc lots of other important interesting
face here for me the book is impressive
for its interdisciplinarity drawing upon
methods of social and cultural history
also compared I think there is a network
of activists on forms of capturing
exchange environmental studies geography
cultural anthropology archaeology
etcetera etcetera
yeah of course this work has not go
unrewarded mini-crisis more than 12
major awards in 2003 few of them where
the Bancroft war conclude a university
for overseeing history of America's
Francis Parkman prize from the Society
of American Historians the frederick
jackson turner the best first book in
American history of the air me wheeler
woman prize in the American Society for
history etc we're getting on for the
new book project may cesaro's
archaeology coffee and a ghost of a
walker white of the window which is
coming up learn is a sort of michael
history of massacre in seven hundred of
the
hoping community by federal cookies in
it James will present us as a sort of
irrational tale varying perspectives to
our native tool to get story in the of
historical archaeology and packs crafts
and most importantly the ways in which
the tales been told that we told
stressed and suppressed by hoagies
Native American activists and others in
the last few centuries it's the story of
the question about the question of who
ought to own the past and one suggesting
work again more than one explanation for
communal violence okay so that's the
scholarly aspect what I also wanted to
emphasize is where James come from comes
from institutionally he spent had
historical positions in history
departments at the University of
Maryland University of California Santa
Barbara UC Berkeley Easton for Advanced
Study etc etc but he's here today as
president and CEO of the school for
advanced research on the human
experience and set to fame New Mexico
that the the school was established in
1907 a study for the archaeology and
ethnology the American Southwest and
since nineteen sixty seven the scope of
the school's activities have embraced
the global perspective through programs
to encourage advanced scholarship and
anthropology I related social science
disciplines in the humanities and and
especially to facilitate the work of
Native American scholars and artists it
has an extensive campus 30 staff members
etc etc the school realizes its mission
through an array of programs programs
including fellowships for scholars and
residents week-long gatherings of
scholars surprises residential
fellowships for Native American artist
and SAR press which publishes great
books new in the field etc I said again
I'm cutting sure but I think the school
prevents research exemplifies a kind of
exciting and productive interest rate as
canaries spending our team at ease and
social sciences that I think do serve as
an inspiration for us here at her knee
bone and it was simply our society most
important for the topic at hand today
I'm finally getting to settle your fault
items optional where so much is ours of
any arts Research Center when world's
most significant collections of
Southwest native american arts and
artifacts found in 1922 and span the
corner 50-year period from the spanish
period spanish contact and conquest and
present and in as president of the
school for advanced research jynxbox has
not only transformed the school in
exciting ways as into a dynamic and
cutting-edge institution but one of the
ways they have done so in the past five
years as i'm sure we learned today is in
transforming the nature and purpose of
the Indian arts research center during
vicious outreach to Native communities
who have become actively involved in the
sector James Brooks is talk today is
entitled once again connecting with
indigenous communities through
indigenous art collections why
thank you Paul that was that was quite
spectacular and incredibly boring right
like I don't want to hear this guy go on
and on and on but no it's really
wonderful that Paul welcomed me here I
was going to be in Pittsburgh anyway
doing what I really do at SAR which is
raise money daily every day to keep the
doors open and and I thought wait I know
people in Pittsburgh and how about I
come and you know visiting all he said
how I'm running the setter why don't you
come and give a talk about Indian arts I
said well I don't know anything about it
no it's all I do is run this place right
but I know that's the secret to
administrators is in fact we know
nothing about what we administer but if
you're good as an administrator you hire
really good people who do know what
they're doing and that's a lot of what I
want to talk about today that I'm just
going to give you a quick story about
and aware this collection comes from we
have nearly 13,000 pieces of absolutely
the best southwest Native art from from
the time of contact up until the present
the collection continues to grow we have
a strong emphasis on contemporary 21st
century art you'll get a sense of that
and and but it's got a history and it's
a history that began you know now over a
hundred years ago and that has gone
through a lot of changes and I think
actually it gives us an opportunity to
look at kind of the history of
anthropology the history of art
collecting the history of the
relationship between indigenous peoples
and we who study them and this glue this
gradual arc toward self empowerment and
the engagement of indigenous peoples in
the stewardship and the curation and the
management of these collections so
that's why I came up with this kind of
tongue-twisting but I think very poetic
title though it is a little hard to roll
out well that didn't do anything there
we go this this is where I work
it's kind of nice it's I was really glad
that I chose this slide to show up this
is the administration building where my
office is located and I took this a year
and a day ago it was the first snow that
we had had in Santa Fe and I just heard
from my kids this morning that we had
our first snow last night in Santa Fe so
the timing was perfect and and as you
can see we had both leaves on the trees
turning yellow and some snow on the
ground the the building you see there
was originally a residence I'll tell you
something about that residence it's
modeled on the mission church at Laguna
Pueblo which is west of Albuquerque
about 40 miles it's about a 75-percent
scale model of that mission church
precise to every detail the corbels the
lateeya there's a herringbone lateeya
pattern in the in the ceiling that's
that's reproduced and so there's kind of
this immediate architectural connection
to the very communities that we're
attempting to engage with now and who's
who's artistic production we have the
honor of stewarding as Paul mentioned we
now are one of the what we hope to be
one of the leading centers for Advanced
Study in social sciences humanities and
the indigenous arts this is just a quick
snapshot of some of the things we've
done in the last 12 months in upper left
we have an active publishing program we
publish about a dozen titles a year that
flow either through the scholarly
programs of the school we produce a
series called the advanced seminar
series that's now 42 years old and if
you are a self-respecting anthropologist
you really kind of have to have all of
these edited volumes or we hope this is
what's called niche dominance I really
like that because like when we produce a
book if you're going to stay current you
kind of got to buy it if you're like and
that makes us happy but we also produce
books for the for the general popular
audience this is david grant nobles most
recent book he's done several
for us in the places of spirits it's a
combination memoir archaeological memoir
of his explorations in the southwest and
the first time he has ever linked that
to his own photography is a spectacular
photographer and this is one aspect of
the mission of SAR that I really embrace
and and it drives me crazy every day but
I love it every day and that was when
the school was founded by Edgar Lee
Hewitt 104 years ago he wrote a mission
statement that not only were we going to
support the Advanced Study especially in
American Archaeology produce a cadre of
professionals who could rival the
professional class working in the
Mediterranean but we also had the
mandate to communicate that knowledge to
the general public or the interested
public as we now call it we decided not
to try to reach the general public
because they don't care but there is an
interesting book Oh makes it a lot
easier and and this is a constant
struggle and I think everyone here
probably knows that that it is not easy
to translate the kinds of esoteric
knowledge produced by scholars to even
an interested public it's a real
challenge but it's one that we embrace
one of my favorite stories though is our
one of the first trustees of SAR back in
1907 was Franz Boas rather spectacular
big name and anthropology once this
mission statement was adopted he
resigned in protest because he said you
can't do both you cannot support the
best anthropological scholarship and
reach the general public he said you're
going to dumb down everything you do if
you do though and so here's one of the
great grandfather's one of the founding
fathers of American anthropology he said
you can't do it and we've been doing it
for 104 years we were happy with that in
the center you have purnima pi the potty
for the University of Chicago she was
with us this summer working on a history
of military ethnography in northern
India how the tribal zones of northern
India were constructed through british
military ethnographers on the right are
five of our resident scholars who are
with us this year for nine month
residences include
on the far right there are a new fellow
that we've just brought in under a new
fellowship that we launched this year
jameelah bar gosh is from Morocco and
she is is the first Campbell fellow
working in what we call women's economic
empowerment the anthropology of economic
development and she works on this
astonishing I want to know if anybody
has heard of this fog harvesting
technology and the Atlas Mountains of
Morocco that these mountains every night
get these amazing fog banks rolling in
as the heat of the Sahara sucks the
moisture in off the ocean the fog builds
up and she's him she's building these
very simple Nets of propylene nets
outside these villages to catch the fog
and then they condense come down into an
overnight collection systems and you two
or three of these net systems there's
only like 140 square feet or something
put together can supply fresh water
daily for women who usually have to walk
three or four miles a day to the village
wells in order to get it so we have that
kind of very applied aspects going on
others and i know i'm not going to walk
through everybody there but with on the
left you have Melissa Nelson who is
Turtle Mountain Chippewa she's working
on on the Reconstruction and
preservation of the Paiute salt song
trail the Pirates have historically
traveled ceremonially a thousand mile
trail in the Great Basin in order to
mark their own on kind of ontological
emergence narrative and there were songs
that went in in tandem with its thousand
mile trail she's been working now for
about a decade with the pipes to
preserve these songs both digitally and
in and in performance and so she's with
us to to help bring those back to the
Pirates as they completed and 2pi youth
especially we also host Native artists
this is Marla Allison she is from Laguna
Pueblo where are one of our buildings is
modeled she's a painter but she was
brought she came
to us as a fellow specifically she said
I I want to paint but I want to paint
inspired by the pottery of my own Pueblo
and so here she is with the Akuma Laguna
very small portion of the Akuma Laguna
collection holding one of our earliest
Laguna pots and behind her are two
panels of what was ultimately a four
panel painting that she did where she
picked up the design some of the design
motifs out of the pottery and put them
into this is a landscape view of the red
mesas around Laguna Pueblo village so
she's folding together landscape and
design elements into into a single piece
of work and viola is one of these just
emerging young artists that is going to
be really exciting to to watch she's
also a super like Ninja Warrior she
participates in all sorts of martial
arts and is quite apparently celebrated
for that but a really delightful person
and then on the left is a seminar that
we just hosted in in June that seminars
are usually thought of as being kind of
stayed in boy no kind of bow tie kinds
of things this is a seminar that
celebrated the hundredth year of the
passing of katherine dunham who was an
anthropologist and a dancer much more
renowned as a dancer and that ran the
Dunham School in East st. Louis but
during her whole career as Katherine
Dunham she kind of quietly published in
anthropology as k done and she's really
known as the first person to come and
create an anthropology of dance looking
at dance as cultural expression and
performance and so these are all both
academics and simultaneously dancers who
came together and not only did they do
the classic seminar of exchanging papers
and talking about them and all but they
also host they led a master class for
Santa Fe youth at the National Dance
Institute in Santa Fe and taught the
Dunham technique
for a day so this is kind of it gives
you a sense of the kind of outreach that
we're trying to do to reach new people
in the community but to go back to the
beginning and this is the kind of is
important in terms of the collection we
were established by Edgar Lee Hewitt
1907 of the School of American
Archaeology specifically to create a
cohort of professional archaeologists
who would investigate the archeological
wonders of the southwest and keep the
stuff here what Hewitt saw happening and
was happening by 1907 was that
archaeologists of the classical world in
Europe and the almost Europe meaning
Harvard to him we're coming into the
southwest and and basically pot hunting
these these archaeological sites in
order to get the the pottery especially
if here's a piece of biscuit where and
Hewitt wanted the stuff to stay in New
Mexico to stay in the southwest and he
thought that our archaeological wonders
where every bit is important as those of
the classical world so he founds the
School of American Archaeology this is
his bandelier national monument the guy
in the dark is Edgar Lee Hewitt himself
they're beginning to excavate up in what
are called the cave eights you can see
an aerial view of Chu only which is one
of the major Pueblo is there and of
course it's now a national monument
where we get about a quarter of a
million visitors a year going up and
hiking the canyons and this is the first
of four ladders 140 feet up into the
canyon to get to a place called
ceremonial cave but what's the school
dist doing is doing archaeology and
especially in this period archaeology
meant digging stuff up and putting it in
collections this is kind of how we began
to get into the collections business it
also created right out the gate a
somewhat difficult relationship because
indigenous peoples in the southwest
weren't exactly thrilled to have white
archaeologists running around digging up
all their burials right because where
you're going to find the best stuff the
pottery that's preserved and not broken
or the paw hose the prayer sticks the
jewelry and what
are associated with burials so here we
are in 1907 were already in the
grave-robbing business and that's going
to come to be an issue by the 1970s
we've expanded and we've become the
School of American research at that
point we were supporting global
scholarship but we are also running our
own continuing archaeological
investigations this is the site of
arroyo hondo Pueblo which is just a few
miles south of Santa Fe you can see in
the aerial photograph the remain the
bounds of the room blocks here this is
an aerial photograph of our excavations
that were ongoing throughout the 1970s
supported by the National Geographic
Society National Science Foundation neh
this was the most extensive and thorough
multi-year archaeological research
project for any single site in the
southwest we've pronounced nine volumes
of scholarly analysis everything from
faunal remains to pottery to organic
materials to the architecture space
syntax everything out of this site and
here you see a reconstruction of what to
say it was about a thousand rims
probably had at its maximum residents of
four or five hundred indigenous
ancestral Pueblo in peoples and of
course a lot of pottery this is a
classic Santa Fe black on white piece
that came out of that in in at the end
of the excavations we had 325,000
specifically tagged and inventoried
items that came out of this and it was a
really really important project from for
the archaeological knowledge that we
were able to produce from it that each
of these plazas it's an interesting
story that the very top plaza is the
first Plaza and then over periods of
three to five years new clauses are
added and it's all by people new people
immigrant people coming in and joining
and growing this community it seems like
that's a you know a pretty neat story of
them coming together
well we also did was an extensive
investigation of the regional sustaining
area that in terms of the capacity to
grow corn and beans and squash the wild
game available everything from dear to
rabbits to my sort of thing and we
realized that by the time those third
and fourth and five fifth plazas are
being added that people had well
exceeded the sustaining capacity of the
region and when people started looking
at the nearly 300 individual human
remains that we took out of this site
you could see Ostia logically that every
new immigrating group of people were
increasingly malnourished and stressed
to the point that the children being
born in some of those later plazas are
being born with rickets they're being
born malnourished right this is not a
happy place in the last generation of it
of its occupation and that's part of one
of the challenges that confront us
because I mentioned we we took nearly
300 people out of this and we house them
at SAR and we had a repository that has
these three hundred and twenty-five
thousand objects plus 300 people or so
and when it came to our relationships
within whoops I don't want to go there
with indigenous people this uh although
we never were public in any major way
about the fact that we had this huge
collection it was a research collection
no but Indian country knew that there
were relatives were being housed on this
campus and when I became president there
had been you know we work entirely
compliant with nagpur Native American
graves protection repatriation Act we
had reported all of our holdings
catalogued them made them public so
claimant communities could come one of
the challenges for us was that no
contemporary Pueblo Community made a
claim on Royal ando as being ancestral
which meant we had no community
work with in terms of the repatriation
and reburial process when I became
president we were then confronted with
how are we going to deal with this that
we know we do not want to have these
human remains on our campus anymore
because of one we're done you know the
analysis is done and besides it's
presenting a real issue of comfort for
our Indian neighbors and so luckily we
were able to work out an agreement with
Zia Pueblo the folks that that were
physically the closest community there
in between Santa Fe and Albuquerque to
act as a consulting group for us and we
went through almost a year-long process
of working with their cultural
preservation officers of Zia Pueblo and
spiritual advisers from that Pueblo some
of the elders there to how do we manage
the process of reburying the citizens of
oil and of Pueblo we went through it was
it was a long and complicated
preparation process and then finally the
day came and the site had been prepared
and I physically put every one of those
people back in the ground we had really
deep deep trenches and the trenches were
so unstable once we got below the
caliche that I really was making me
nervous about having anybody down there
so what I did is over the course of a
rather long day as I rode the backhoe
bucket up and down up and down carrying
these people and putting them back where
they belong so that was one really
important step that we went through and
and it was it was a big relief to me to
everyone at SAR and to our the are
indigenous constituents who we want to
work with so that kind of gives you a
sense of the archaeological background
there's also the story of our patrons
who gave us this campus and i hope this
kind of looks familiar that this this is
that very same building you saw in that
first photograph pretty much the day it
was completed in 1927 this is in a state
that was me
named by its creators L delirio the
madness or our madness and I started out
as 350 acres it's now eight acres they
basically bought the whole east side of
Santa Fe and developed that but one of
them who you'll meet in a moment served
on our Board of Trustees for nearly 40
years and when she passed on in 1972 the
elderly real estate became the campus
for SAR we had been downtown in a
building near the palace of the
governor's and suddenly we we had this
like campus but this is this is how it
began and these owners were interesting
women Amelia and Martha root white had
come to Santa Fe in the early 20s in an
open touring car driving across the
country in order to view a total eclipse
of the Sun on the Pacific coast after
several weeks I think of driving in an
open Turing cart their hair was a mess
so they stopped in Santa Fe to have
their hair done so goes the story and
they fell in love with Santa Fe and they
became part of this phenomenon of young
wealthy white women who flocked to the
southwest in the early decades of the
20th century because the Southwest
represented some kind of an alternative
especially for women to the kinds of
transformations that were going on in
the United States at this time they saw
Native communities Pueblo people
especially Pueblo women living but it
seemed to them to be of much much more
empowered lives engaging in lives where
they had the respect of their community
and so Santa Fe became this mecca for
highly a kind of experimental white
women to come and have fun and boy did
they have a lot of fun as you can see
this is Amelia on her horse preparing to
ride in the Santa Fe fiesta parade next
to her on the right is we have Amelia on
the far left
Martha on the far right and Paul being a
Mayan astir Lee you recognize the
sacrificial attire that they're dressed
in here is anybody want to guess what's
going on here on that platform they are
sacrificing the virgin in order to
celebrate the completion of Santa Fe's
first swimming pool and that's what's
behind that adobe wall is basically a
concrete tub that's about like 18 feet
long and four feet deep and and 10 feet
wide and that is the first swimming pool
that Santa Fe ever had and they
inaugurated it with him with the sindh
odata sacrifice where they tossed one of
this this virginal maiden in to to mark
you know and it's like it today it kinda
makes you cringe to imagine they're
doing this but they had together and
they were totally connected Scott and
Zelda Fitzgerald hung out at El delirio
the Lindbergh's hung out at lville area
we even have an aerial photo the Charles
Lindbergh took as he zoomed the estate
we also had the first tennis court in
Santa Fe and we still do it's the only
clay court in New Mexico we still have
to keep that up even though that was
play tennis so here are these to like
powerful kinds of like social and
artistic movers coming to santa fe and
one of the things that gets their
interest is the fate of Indian art by
the 1920 rly 1920s they are
participating in and creating something
that could is called the Indian arts
fund which ultimately will become the
collection that you'll be seeing shortly
the way this story goes is that Amelia
and Martha were at a party and a little
at an estate up into Suki village north
of Santa Fe when they partied a lot and
at this party you know people had bought
pottery you know next to the railroad
and all and and this pot was featured at
the party it's Anna she be polychrome
jar from Zuni Pueblo dated to about 1780
he and apparently somebody got into
their martinis and somebody dropped the
pot and it shattered and there was this
kind of collective stunned a moment
where the people gathered at the party
realized that this was a moment when
this beautiful artistic tradition was
headed toward its its passing because
people in Indian Potter's had stopped
making these spectacular big vessels and
we're beginning to produce really tiny
little pots you could sell down to the
railroad tracks for a nickel or a dime
and so Amelia and Martha and their
friends created the Indian arts fund
specifically to go out and purchase and
preserve and perpetuate II the best of
the best of southwest native artistry
specifically it started with pottery and
then expanded into textiles and and
other media they hired Ken Chapman who
is the kind of a legendary ceramics
expert to be their advisor ken was not
not professionally trained in any way
other than he was an artist himself but
he really became a student of the art
form here on the upper left he is with
Maria Martinez herself from San
Ildefonso Pueblo who becomes one of the
truly legendary Potter's in the
southwest he was was there curator for
this collection and to give you an idea
of just how awkward this relationship is
from our perspective today what they
wanted was the best of the best right
they wanted to preserve in their
collections that have the epic moment
and so Ken Chapman would go out to San
Ildefonso Pueblo and Maria would show
line up you know there's six or eight or
ten pots that she had made and he would
walk along with a stick and he would
systematically break them he'd say yeah
not good enough
no he say this one and he'd give her
five bucks and that he break it eats
when what ken was doing was creating an
aesthetic he was saying this is what I
believe to be the finest of your
artistic production and I will continue
to give you five dollars apart as long
as you can continue to make this kind of
quality of work so looking back you kind
of do not have you cringe quite public
is like ah this is awful and yet at the
same time that they're creating this
collection the sisters are also hosting
the first-ever public art show of
Southwest Arts in Santa Fe at the armory
where you have hundreds of the best of
the best of different kinds of artistic
traditions represented there they
because of their connections anybody
know who the the White was that they
might have been connected to the Horace
Mann white publisher the Chicago Tribune
and the New York Post was her was their
father and so they had these connections
to back east when they host an art show
everybody turns out because Scott and
Zelda is going to be there you know
Charles and Hannah going to be there
they single-handedly drive and create a
market for something that had never had
a kind of a cash market before and so at
the same time that they're doing this
you know incredibly patronizing
condescending kind of aesthetic curation
of an art form that had never been
intended to be you know they aimed at
this kind of a market they're also
literally they are rescuing and creating
a demand for high-quality arts that you
know can continues today that's how we
get into the business of having a
collection and this is what that Indian
arts fund became at SAR this is the shot
into one of two are literally we call
them vaults and they are vaults the
walls around these are you know three or
four feet
thick they're reinforced with all sorts
of concrete rebar the doors to entry of
these are classic bank vault doors you
know that I can't get into because they
never tell me any of the of the codes to
allow me in but luckily we have got
people who who will when I asked and yet
here we have in vault one on the bottom
floor about seven thousand pieces of
pottery and it is the best of the best
in okay this was the curation treated in
the accession tradition that that
Chapman established and it's organized
by first by language family and then by
Pueblo and what you see here is kind of
a on the left how the collection in some
ways was was used for many years and
that was simply to shock and awe it was
a great place to bring my donors right
my visitors and I always say hey you
want to see something really nice and
you open the bank vault and you and they
go who the jaws drop because it's all
open storage there's no variance there's
no nothing it's like this stuff is just
sitting out there you have so in seven
or eight thousand pieces of pottery we
have hundreds of pieces of basketry 735
of the best Navajo textiles that are out
there more than 600 cut Cena's the Hopi
and Zuni Coco's in that collection it is
an astonishing thing what's great about
the picture on the left is it was only
shot in August and what we're seeing
here is native peoples from the
communities that produce this work
acting as interpreters for this event
that we hosted for trustees and our
people and I'll help you get to there so
it's this is this is how shock and awe
might have looked but in fact what
you're seeing here is an entirely
different experience there is not a
white curator telling the story of this
stuff you got
j garcia hear in the background from
santa clara pueblo he's talking about
his own work and the work that we have
in the center that inspired him to do
the kind of work that he's doing today
so this this is a pretty exciting
transformation in process how did we get
there and this is where I get to take a
little credit I was really fortunate
within my first couple of years of
stepping into the job to know that there
were some very good and incredibly
talented native professionals who were
coming up and into the job market I
hired dr. Cynthia Chavez Lamar back in
two thousand seven she had done her
training she had a doctorate from UNM
university of new mexico in marin
cultural studies she had done her
training at NMAI in in DC she was the
curator if you've been there of the
exhibit called our lives which was a
collaborative curation project of
looking at contemporary indian
communities in their artistic production
across hemispherical e we have people
peoples from chile and all the way up
into Alaska represented there she was it
was the curator of that and she was from
there therefore from the very beginning
really committed to collaborative and
consultative relationships with the very
communities who were represented there
she is from San Felipe Pueblo so she's
one of the Rio Grande peoples but she's
also in her typical kind of complicated
family ways that we see so much down
there she's also connected to hope
etowah out at polako and navajo as well
so she has the capacity to connect with
a lot of different communities and as
she says listen if I can get along with
myself then all you all you other
Indians I'd be able to get along too
because she's they're not not always
happy relationships and those different
things Laura L if we brought in as
collections manager she's Choctaw she
has a degree in anthropology from I
think at Southern Illinois University as
well as as a continued
training in collections care and
management and she is right now we're
supporting her in pursuing her own
doctorate at UNM in the in the same
American Studies the Cultural Studies
program that dr. Chavez Lamar went
through Sylvain aspall is Raymond Navajo
he's our collections assistant and he
did his his undergraduate training at
dinnae college and then went on to do
some more training up at Fort Lewis
College in in Durango and Sylvain is
he's absolutely the best textiles guy
because he grew up with Navajo textiles
he grew up in a weaving community he's
fluent in Navajo he's able when we bring
the grandmothers in for these
collections visit there's someone there
who knows the cultural protocols for
helping them come in and understand it
and enjoy the collection so indigenous
the staff was a really important for
Stefan everything that fed has flowed
subsequently really is to their credit
we have always had for nearly you know
40 years in it Native artists residences
but with with Cynthia and her staff
coming in it began to get really fun and
exciting because not only do you have
people like Sherri Farrell recette matey
from Canada we're suddenly outside of
the Southwest we're outside of the
national borders working in you know a
fairly traditional form she's beating
here but she's also a writer and
illustrator children's book author and
an academic so she's mixing and matching
all sorts of different perspectives she
was with us a year ago Elijah naranjo
here in the middle at the top is the
daughter of Nora naranjo Morris wanted
really legendary artist in the southwest
and but Elijah uh didn't want to be a
Potter she wanted to be a painter but
she wanted to do something different so
what she did is use the collection to
inspire her to you work in a new media
painting she's painting with clay all of
her pigments
are derived from the very clay that is
used throughout the collection in
producing pots but instead she uses it
as a paint you have a guy a Choctaw guy
Jeff Gibson here on the right he was
inspired by looking at at the weavings
in the collection to play with weaving
motifs in a very contemporary and
abstract style that's a painting behind
him there where he's picking up on some
of the notions of the warp and the weft
that he's seeing in these traditional
Navajo rugs but doing something entirely
different with it and and Jeff he lives
in New York shows in New York very edgy
contemporary guy but but able to make
that leap between tradition and
innovation we have here I cedar sherbert
filmmaker brought in completely you know
people going what how come Indian
Indians make film what he's a
screenwriter he's working on on its
California Indian working on a
screenplay there Erica Lord is Alaskan
native she said she does performance art
very very fun different kinds of stuff
and is a very playful person and even
pat courtly heart and gold here on the
Left washoe basket maker also I used to
teach up at the Community College there
and computer skills so she's very adept
in contemporary media but what she did
is take some of her materials from
Oregon the Washoe country and they'll
sit then mixed them with southwestern
materials and got into producing these
monster wall hanging pieces that so
she's not like making a little
traditional basket all the time she's
really innovating and pushing the edges
we also brought in communities invited
them to come with and to help us to
understand the collection this is Jimmy
note who's the director of the
Chihuahuan Museum at Zuni Pueblo and Jim
came over because why don't we add
specific answer this is just a sampling
of our Zuni pots here hundreds is any
possible we had we noticed in in the in
the collections records of 30 sub pieces
if I remember
that had where a designated pseudo
ceremonial and we thought what's going
on here we got to be really careful
about this because we don't we should
not have out for public display pottery
that was is is truly ceremonial in
nature and so Jim came over and and
looked at this stuff and in fact began
to identify that you know maybe some of
these were a little a little problematic
but this what in the center here is was
most fascinating because first you if
you look at it in the top he's looking
at gym looks at it okay so we have to
step cloud motif we have the fertility
motifs we have a lot of stuff in there
that would suggest that this was
probably achievable and probably should
not you know be something that that is
out there but then you look inside and
Jim kind of laughs and he says well no I
don't think so that because kiba Bulls
are for making a foodstuff that can be
shared ceremonially and he says well no
that's not going to work with that frog
down in the bottom you're not going to
be able to stay and so we what we found
is that these pseudo ceremonials whereas
onra that traders specifically asked
Zuni Potter's to make in the 20s and 30s
because they knew that there was a
fascination among collectors about these
ceremonial objects and so they'd go out
and say can you make us a ceremonial
pocket you know Kiva pot that we can
sell and the zuni's would say sure now
no problem and and yet they would kind
of quietly find ways of not you know
kind of subverting the ceremonial nature
of it by adding a frog or something or
in this case adding a hole that's not
going to work very well for doing food
and in the Kiva's so we were able it was
a great consultation because we were
able to distinguish between those truly
ceremony in nature and those that were
produced specifically for the tourist
trade and yet as any Potter's were able
to kind of protect themselves from
sharing any critical ceremonial
knowledge there also came out of this
consultation really exciting
breakthrough where
jim was there and and he sees this this
ring the pot rang in the upper left
corner in our collection he says what is
that I've never I don't know what's
going on with that and as he studies and
thinks about it he thinks about the Zuni
oya maidens who have been dancing for
millennia with these these pots on their
heads and he says wait a minute you know
I think what those rings are is that
they used to be made to help carry the
pot on your head he says we don't do
that anymore that our maidens have to
dance with it like movies live and it's
not so what Jim was able to do was to go
back to the Pueblo find a weaver who had
some kind of vague recollection of how
these might have been made and they come
back to SAR with materials these are
yuca leaves from the inside of a very
very special very narrowly yucca plant
and they work and work and find out you
can like we've it by putting it around
with tin can you can help shape it right
and through this process Jim is able
basically to rebirth a whole weaving
tradition out as any Puebla there now
teaching as any potters and Zuni kids
how to produce these these pot rings
that that he had not even seen ever in
his own life so this is one of those
really successful moments where by
committing ourselves to these
conversations with our indigenous
communities were able to really give
back in positive ways we also hosted a
seminar a couple of years ago on we had
fifty three pairs of moccasins in our
collection that we're not really well
documented at all so we brought in
moccasin makers from six different
communities Apaches pueblos zuni's and
all throughout the southwest and we
looked at these systematic and carefully
and actually are now developing cynthia
Chavez is working on a traveling exhibit
that will talk about this process as
well as all of these markets and makers
made moccasins they
based on many of these old designs but a
classic example of how we can learn from
these consultations is represented in
these two photographs the upper one is
how we have these Apache moccasins
stored and displayed in our collection
for many many many years and the Apaches
got to look at it you know what are you
guys do in there what they explained to
us was in fact they're supposed to be
rolled down in such a way that you can
see this is this is the way they're
supposed to be preserved and worn then
and so through this consultation we were
able to go whoops we were not doing that
right and and now we can display those
moccasins in the perfectly appropriate
way and and it's been great because it's
really inspired these markets and makers
to get re-engaged in making these and so
we'll be doing this this new exhibit in
the years ahead we also committed
ourselves to youth we created in the
last few years a native internship
program that brings native students who
are post ba and thinking about
professional careers in heritage and
museum management but who need some kind
of a transition period between they're
finishing their undergraduate work and
deciding exactly in which direction they
want to go in professional training and
so we have on the upper left Jessica
Metcalf Turtle Mountain Chippewa who was
our first in turn to Brandi ger in her
came a couple of three years ago Jessica
now has finished her doctorate at the
University of Arizona in American Indian
studies and is holding a postdoc at the
University of New Mexico she works on
native fashion design the history of
Native fashion design for the last
hundred years or so from like Lloyd Kiva
knew who was was a very early Native
fashion designer up until today the very
very edgy crazy stuff that Virgil Ortiz
from from Cochiti Pueblo does so here is
first intern who actually took this and
really launched and moved ahead on it
Gloria Bell who's Beatty from Canada is
working on digital she's with us this
year digital correct curation of maytee
clothing we have Dominic Henry on the
far right who is danae he's finishing a
doctorate now at the University of
Oklahoma he was really fascinated with
Maya work and so he curated a digital
exhibit with us on Maya ceramics in the
body and generally was really fascinated
with the way that the Maya people
represented the human body this year is
well we have Theresa Montoya here she's
Navajo DNA as well and she's working
with some some contemporary Navajo
weavers who are actually men which is
very unusual and she's kind of looking
around to graduate schools I got to go
write her some letters for grad schools
when I get back Olivia meterme hope from
pico display blow is actually a high
school student she's just finishing high
school she came to us from Santa Fe
Indian School she too is looking ahead
and wondering a good track for her
career and finally Kendall Tallmadge
here is Ho Chunk from Wisconsin and she
has just begun a combination of PhD and
Museum Studies program at the University
of Colorado so we're bringing in these
young students who really are using that
year with us as a way of learning about
how to you know the fundamentals of
collections management but also the
intellectual work of becoming a scholar
Cynthia Chavez during her training had
realized there was something insidious
going on with Native students they were
kind of getting tracked into the the
kind of the vocational technical side of
the museum trade registrar collections
man and make that sort of thing
collections care they weren't being
encouraged to pursue the intellectual
side to become academics and thinkers
themselves this program was specifically
designed to help move that forward we
also have an ongoing partnership with
the Santa Fe
indian school that is owned by the
pueblos and has a large residential
program a lot of indian kids come in and
they come and spend time with us again
learning in the kind of the beginning
levels how to research in a collection
how to examine how to how to sketch how
to record the work that goes on and so
we're catching and getting kids involved
very early on and finally just moving in
into other kinds of partnerships that
you know we always kind of had like this
scholars did seminars and Indians did
convocations right because it was like
arts and it was scholarship we now do
Native artists seminars by saying hey
you know you guys you are thinkers and
dreamers in your own right and so get
get to gather your your people together
and let's do really thoughtful scholarly
work you drive it you figure out what
the urgent topics are and take it from
here and so you have nor naranjo morris
involved in a seminar that also included
the Ainu activists from from japan
Miriam shaken who came over and
participated as a performance artist in
looking at the notion of indigeneity
identity and aesthetics we have a
collection here of nearly a dozen Native
artists women from Canada and the United
States who came together and produced
this book that we just launched a couple
of months ago art in our lives Native
women artists and dialogue where they're
really looking at their the many the
role of Native women one as kind of
culturally conservative players as
opposed to conserve and maintain
traditions and yet at the same time or
pushing because they're artists they
want to experiment and play and and find
new modes of expression and the kind of
pushback that they get in those roles
both from the collecting community that
wants to see Native women being
traditional and from their own
communities that may not want to see
Native women in these highly
experimental
modes and so we continue to play with
this as ways of really reinforcing the
kind of the combination and simultaneity
of artistic expression and and
intellectual engagement that all of our
native constituents bring to it this is
a book that i did with gloria emerson a
navajo painter who also i discovered was
an extraordinary poet and so we work
together and i served as the
developmental editor on this publication
where people were gone whoa you got a
Navajo woman who not only can paint in
these really strange and wonderful
abstract forms but also writes beautiful
poetry that combines Navajo and English
in a single poem so that's my talk for
this evening it gives you a sense of how
was collection has changed over the last
hundred years or so and I'm happy to
take questions thank you very much